(water dripping)
(slow music)
- To play the instrument that
is utilizing our gentle Earth,
it's like you're becoming
one with the instrument
in a very true way.
You just sit and go, yes.
We're looking at The
Great Stalacpipe Organ
of the Luray Caverns in Luray, Virginia.
When I press a key, it
sends an electrical pulse
up to a rubber-tipped mallet,
which strikes the stalactite,
causing it to vibrate, and
producing a incredibly beautiful
musical tone.
The area that the
strikers cover is roughly
three and a half acres,
which then makes it literally
the world's largest musical instrument.
(water dripping)
It is a very gentle sound, very peaceful.
There's only one like it in the world,
and it's something incredibly different
and wonderfully beautiful.
(water dripping)